we have some cool streets for five
minutes
Megan Lee stallion and Kylie Jenner just
brought back hot girl summer but the
whole thing has fans saying huh I love
it the rapper and the beauty mogul hung
out on Saturday and went live on
Instagram rocking gold and black bikinis
with rapper Tory Lanez
during a little fireside pool chat but
it wasn't what they said or did that got
fans heads totally spinning it was the
fact that they were hanging out at all
I'm excited about it as fans were quick
to point out on Twitter the savage
rapper is friends with Jordan was you
know things happen and of course I'm
sorry and apologetic as much as I can be
yeah that Jordan was the Jordan Woods
who used to be besties with Kylie until
they had a major falling out after that
whole Tristan Thompson cheating scandal
that rocked the kardashian-jenner family
and we did quote there's something about
Megan D stallion and Kylie Jenner
hanging out together that doesn't sit
well with my spirit while another said
now wait a damn minute eight Megan and
Jordan like besties Savage
Jordan and Meg have seemingly spent a
lot of time together since last year
last summer the 22 year old shared these
sexy snaps on Instagram alongside the
caption real hot girls having a hot girl
summer just is basically about having
confidence being conned being a life
with a party just being unapologetically
you like you just have to be in love
with yourself you know what I'm saying
you have to spread that love okay so we
aren't sure if Jordan and Megan are
still friends but one thing's for sure
by Megan's definition she and Kylie are
definitely slaying hot girl summer make
sure it's like the best version you know
the hot girl summer ever what is the hot
girl do during the winter we're about to
get into the fall Yeah right so first of
all we're going back to school yeah
school is starting back so it's about to
be a hot nerd semester that's my girl
semester you know what I'm saying
[Music]